I don't prove the top why not the top
for a bra
what
sister
Savannah Chrisley totally trolled by her
sister Chloe I have so many realizations
as the Chrisley Knows Best star parents
Chloe and their brother Grayson while
their parents Todd and Julie are behind
bars I'm helping to raise my 10 year old
sister and 16 year old brother in the
aftermath Sabine has been documenting
the more lighthearted moments on her
Instagram story dance parties
and the latest all right so we're
shopping yeah
and I don't prove the top but we
definitely approve of this moment on
Wednesday Chloe giving Sav her brutally
honest opinion
the pants went good right your pants are
good not to talk okay why not the top I
like the Hat though that you hate to
have okay why not the top it's too
cropped
and the final verdict I need to wear a
bra with it what
roasted sister
I didn't hurt your Papa's feelings yes
she did Chloe yeah that playful Dynamic
might look familiar to fans of Chrisley
Knows Best I feel like we are at a stage
of our life where we need to find where
we're going to settle of course the
reality series looks a little different
in its 10th season I want Grayson to be
settled the last few years he's at home
before he goes to college Chloe is nine
she likes stability so far no mention of
Todd and Julie's convictions for bank
fraud and tax evasion or the couples
combined 19-year prison sentence if Todd
and Julie could share a message with the
world what do you think they'd want them
to know you know I think they'd want
folks to know that they are the same
people they've always been that they
didn't do these things and they're going
to fight to get their name cleared
meanwhile Savannah's next chapter
navigating romance while taking care of
her siblings and I'm trying to date what
do you do with them you know I'm a 16
year old adult you know he drives all
that but the 10 year old I'm like okay
well I mean you've got to maybe come
have dinner with me you've got it like
so from the beginning it's really always
all of you yeah and not just you and
that person I think it's probably the
best that could only be allowed to grow
up as any other 10 year old would yeah
being a 10 year old is hard no matter
what circumstances are well limit these
circumstances Savannah is making sure
Chloe hangs on to her sense of humor
sister
foreign